I call his velarion i lord hobot
hightower promise to be faithful
i swear this by the old gods and the new
is basically a feudal society it's ruled by
many noble houses some of them going back
hundreds or even thousands of years two
of the biggest players are the valerions
and the hightowers the height i was from a very
ancient wealthy powerful household you know we've
been front and center of politics for hundreds
of years the high tower sigil has a torch on it
and their motto is we light the way that comes
across within the characters of the high towers
their seat of power is the southern coast old town
which was for many thousands of years the biggest
city in westeros the faith was headquartered there
for many years that was where the high septon our
equivalent of pope had his seat within the series
you have old gods and new gods and the seven is
new religiosity and the high towers have a strong
connection with the high septum when we first
open the series otto hightower is hand of the
king and i think there's a high tower fire there
there's a saying when the king eats the hand
shits he steers the small council on the king's
behalf when it's necessary and ensures the king's
wishes are enforced otto's an advisor but viserys
is quite suspicious of him otto sees the danger in
everything and even though his intentions are good
he's also persuaded himself that there is
nothing but good intention behind his action
the gods have yet to make a man who lacks
the patience for absolute power your grace
Welcome back everyone it's charlie i've gotten
a lot of requests to do a house of the dragon
video for house hightower since we really didn't
get to see them a lot during the main show game
of thrones so i'll explain how they fit into the
story in the history of their house because they
are one of the oldest and most important houses
in ancient westeros going back to before the time
of the original first men like way before the
children of the forest ever created the night
king and the white walkers that's how ancient
their family is if you're new to the channel i'll
be doing videos for all the house of the dragon
episodes just like i did for the main series be
sure to subscribe to get all of them and they just
announced that they renewed the show for season
two but we all knew that they were gonna renew
for season two so many people watched the premiere
episode it broke every record that warner brothers
hbo has like it's the most popular premiere of any
one of the biggest most powerful ancient houses in
a song of ice and fire that they just flat out cut
out of the main show game of thrones they were
still around during the events of game of thrones
they just weren't as active in the story as the
starks the lannisters the tyrells the houses that
they featured the most during that show during
the time where house of the dragon takes place
here around the dance of the dragons they're much
more central to the actual action of the story so
that's why you're seeing so much of them like otto
hightower is the hand of the king for many many
years so they're very close to the center of the
story to say nothing of alicent hightower being so
close to king viserys obviously huge part of the
story we haven't even gotten the older versions of
their characters yet where things really get crazy
with the targaryen civil war so whereas the main
show was mostly like starks and lannisters with
a bunch of other important houses but really it's
starks and lannisters house of the dragon is more
like targaryens in high towers in the clip that i
put at the beginning of this george rr martin and
the actors talk a little bit about the hightower
characters that are important to the story in a
very quick teaser for how they fit into the story
their house motto is we light the way the symbol
of their house the sigil is the high tower itself
the family controls old town where the high tower
is we saw that briefly during the main show the
maester citadel is there that's why samwell goes
there to be trained as a maester the archmaesters
live there it used to be the main port of
westeros up to the time of aegon's conquest
you could say that it was kind of like the capital
of westeros before king's landing was created but
it wasn't actually the capital before the conquest
the seven different kingdoms had mostly just been
seven different petty kings all ruling over
their different realms and because old town
is inside the reach technically the reach was
ruled by house gardner before the conquest so
like during aegon's conquest the high towers were
kind of like a vassal house of house gardener when
people think of the reach they mostly think of the
tyrells the tyrells didn't start ruling the reach
until aegon's conquest because the gardeners did
not bend the knee and they were ruling the reach
so aegon the conqueror soundly defeated their
army and basically replaced them with the tyrells
and said you are now ruling the reach and they
moved into highgarden that's why highgarden is
called highgarden because it was the seat of house
gardener one of the cool differences with the high
towers though is that it's actually said that
their ancestors actually pre-dated the original
first men who crossed over the arm of dorne to
westeros during the age of heroes long before
the first men colonized westeros and started
fighting the children of the forest it's believed
the ancestors of the high towers were a different
group of people who were just a seafaring race
who settled in this area and used it as a
trading post for like ancient valyria geese
the summer isles just like this general region
of the world here so technically the hightower
family descends from a slightly different line
than the original first men but one of the cool
things about their family like their seat is the
high tower itself there are all kinds of rumors
that the maesters believe different theories
about the creation of the hightower because the
original base that the high tower sits on was
constructed before the time of the first men
so maybe someday if they do a show about the first
men just thousands and thousands of years ago in
the timeline we'll learn more about some of these
ancient dead cultures usually you only hear about
them in passing in the books like they don't
discuss them in great detail but like the first
men for instance are just one of many ancient
races a lot of them being dead usually when
you think of westeros you only think of the first
men you think of the andals later in the timeline
but like there are many other ancient cultures
that were around when the first men were around
the current lord hightower on house of the dragon
is otto hightower's older brother we see him in
the trailer here is hobert hightower his chambers
are actually at the top of the high tower itself
within the song of ice and fire it is one of the
great wonders of the world but the actual highest
point in westeros is casterly rock itself just
because the rock casterly rock is built on sits
at a much higher elevation just for comparison
casterly rock sits at a higher elevation than
even the top of the wall that's how high it is in
addition to being a really powerful fortress and
a lighthouse the high tower is so tall people can
also use it as a sundial so like people living in
the area can tell the time just by looking at the
shadow of the hightower because the hightowers had
been so rich and powerful controlling the central
port of westeros for so long house of the dragon
isn't the first time members of their family have
been connected to the targaryen kings since the
conquest the only reason they didn't get in big
trouble during aegon's conquest is because when
the gardeners stood against aegon the conqueror
and lost the high towers refused to fight for
the gardeners so aegon the conqueror spared their
family in like at the beginning of episode one we
meet the older version of king jaehaerys before
jiharis took the iron throne at age 14 maegor
the cruel was married to one of the hightowers had
a very very bad marriage to her later during his
reign when he continued to become more and more
cruel the current lord hightower helped save the
lives of one of maegor's relatives one of the
targaryen princesses who he'd ordered beheaded
and then the hightowers supported jaehaerys's
claim to the iron throne which he eventually won
which basically brought them into much greater
favor where you see them in house of the dragon
now under viserys rule and even though we haven't
actually been to the great sept on house of the
dragon yet it exists right here you see it in
all the trailers as george rr martin says before
aegon's conquest the faith center of power was
in old town with the high towers for thousands
of years so the high towers themselves as a family
have had a deep connection with the faith of the
seven for a long time that's why you see the older
version of alicent hightower here next to the iron
throne wearing their symbol around her neck the
seven-pointed star and going forward because
we're talking about the dance of the dragons the
targaryen civil war the blacks versus the greens
because alicent hightower as you see in all the
episode 2 trailers becomes viserys's second wife
and queen the hightowers are like the leading
backers of the greens in the dance of the dragons
after episode one a lot of people were also asking
too if otto hightower was knowingly throwing his
daughter alicent at the king in his grief and at
least the way the actor talks about it rhys ephons
otto hightower thinks that he's doing right by
the king and what's best for him and what's best
for the realm he's not really thinking too much
about the power play that might be going on here
he's like a slightly less hardcore version
of tywin lannister also he's not the head of
his family like tywin lannister was the dynamics
might change a little bit in future episodes but
at least at this point in the timeline he thinks
that he's doing right by a widower and because
he's the hand of the king he wants to ensure
that the realm continues to operate smoothly
so he wants the king to be able to actually be
king and he can't do that in his current state
also side note 2 the whole idea with alicent like
she isn't throwing herself at the king either she
doesn't really care about him in that way she's
just trying to be a really nice person and just
for context predating the beginning of the present
day of the show when she was a little bit younger
she was actually the caretaker for king jaharis
at the end of his life before viserys officially
took the iron throne so she's not meant to be like
a margaery tyrell type of personality she's just
like a really caring person at least at this point
in the timeline like i said things can always
because the hightower family will continue to be
really really important and be involved in a lot
of these really crazy events but if you have any
other questions about what's going on with house